back to the crisis on our southern
border critics accusing the president of
rolling out the red carpet for drug
smugglers
well our next guest has seen the problem
firsthand he writes about it in a new
op-ed it said
black market pot our open border lacks
law enforcement how we fought back in my
district
that man is california republican
congressman mike garcia he's with us now
and sir good morning
to you how did you fight back
hey good morning bill and thank thanks
for having me well we fought back in
what is a shining example of how
government should work for the people
we started getting word about these
illegal grows in the antelope valley the
high deserts of southern california
these are suburbs of
los angeles about six months ago we took
a tour we saw
just how bad it was and it was
heartbreaking to see what these cartels
are doing to our lands
they're they're pillaging our our land
these these groves are being staffed by
uh illegal immigrants they're stealing
our water they're killing our wildlands
and uh and threatening our local
community members and and the local
community members
uh didn't just roll over and play dead
in this case they fought back
they let us know uh we got the attention
of local sheriff villanueva from los
angeles county
and over the course of 10 days with the
help of the dea multiple levels of
federal government four counties
we ended up seizing about 1.2 billion
dollars
with a b of illegal marijuana grows
arrested some 33 individuals 27 firearms
confiscated and about 16 tons of
marijuana which was consuming about 9
million gallons of water a day
uh in a time where california is in the
middle of one of our worst droughts 16
tons yeah so that so the
environmentalists are helping you in
this case
they actually are we've got several
environmental groups coming to our aid
now we found
two bears who were actually killed by
the fertilizers that they ingested
at a few of these grow sites so this is
this is damaging the wildlife this is
ruining the soil around us
it's uh it's obviously a massive threat
to the local residents who are being
threatened on a daily basis
what happened to legalizing members with
the arms i thought that when california
you know if you legalize marijuana i
thought this was supposed to stop
yeah that's the irony of all this
obviously dana this is a shining example
of what happens when
bureaucracy gets in the way even the
legal cannabis business is suffering
because of this
now they've got thousands of illegal
growers that they're competing with that
have a zero-cost basis product
uh and they're they're going to market
uh basically undercutting the legal
market
and meanwhile the legal market has to
pay 47 taxes and deal with california's
bureaucracy right
this is a shining example of what's
going on in california and why the
policies in california
cannot be uploaded to the national level
and the open border crisis right now
uh this this is because of the open
border on our southern borders this is a
man-made
problem where we're seeing cartels now
migrate 300 miles north into our into
our local communities
and president biden has given hope to
the bad guys in this case wow you're
saying grow
g-r-o-w by the way they almost amount to
warehouses the way you describe them if
you're growing 16 tons
you write this too many in america do
not understand how neighborhood security
is intertwined with national security
failure to enforce law and order at the
border and in cities across america
combined with calls that defund the
police
have created a crime crisis across our
great nation
america must stop bowing down the foes
abroad and on our homeland
and start enforcing the law and ensuring
our nation remains
safe and secure clearly you don't think
the administration's got that message
based on that
uh absolutely not like i said this
administration is actually giving hope
to the bad guys whether it's the cartels
on our southern border giving russia a
free pass for cyber attacks
allowing nordstrom 2 to continue uh the
pipeline
uh getting back into the iran deal
removing sanctions against venezuela
going quiet while cubans are struggling
for their freedoms just 90 miles south
of our border
and then not holding china accountable
when we have clear evidence that the the
the virus was uh not only started but
developed engineered
and also disseminated from wuhan uh this
president is
is turning a blind eye to what these bad
guys are doing
and in turn creating a lot of this crime
i mean we're seeing what 100 percent
increase in in major crime and murder
rates uh throughout our nation right now
year over year congresswoman direct
results of these policies and defunding
police sorry to interrupt but
before we go i just think it's important
that there were some dogs that were
rescued
in in this raid as well tell us a little
bit about that and i know that they're
up for
adoption at reverserescue.com
yeah absolutely this was one of the
highlights of the story and absolutely
heartbreaking to see real time on the
ground as we were tearing down these
grows
we found about 180 animals most of them
were dogs that were orphaned as a result
of this
reversed rescue of my friend ty out in
the antelope valley took most of these
dogs in
and they're up for adoption now
absolutely the sweetest dogs and
i got a chance to visit them you see
some of those pictures there uh we're
taking care of the wildlife and uh
and and giving back the the lands and
the water of our residents
back to the community that we uh we we
desperately
need right now and uh these dogs are
benefactors of this operation they're
they're going to be in better hands and
in better homes now they will
thank you sir thank you guys talk to you
and good luck okay thank you guys
appreciate the time matt thank you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now